翻訳: Harue Mori
校正: Tetsuya Kawaguchi
これ 何の数字やと思います？
これは 人生が１週間の連続だとするなら
１週間のうち７日とも
毎日ワクワクして過ごしたいという
僕の人生の目標なんです
いや そんな無理やろって
思いますよね
学生やったら 勉強せなあかんし
社会人やったら 仕事があるし
第一 毎日そんなにワクワクすることなんて
ないやろって
わかります
実は僕も社会人になりたての頃
７/７どころか０/７でした
でもちょっと思い出してほしいんです
子どもの頃って
もっと毎日ワクワクしてませんでした？
いつの間にそれを忘れてしまったんやろ？
それか 大人になると
そんなに毎日
ワクワクせぇへんもんなんかなって
僕はそうは思いません
今日は 僕が経験してきたことが
皆さんが今よりもワクワクして過ごすための
ヒントになればと思います
僕は小さい頃から
好きなことしかしない子どもで
それ以外 一切しませんでした
小学生の頃は 『頭の体操』という
パズルの本にハマって
中学生になると 数学が好きで
そればっかりやってました
だからもう他の教科が全くダメで
高校には行かれへんかもしれんって
思ってたぐらい
特に英語が苦手で
一度だけ試験勉強
徹夜でやったことがあるんですけど
試験開始直後に
もう眠すぎて 気絶した挙句
いつもより悪い10点しか取れなくて
もうそれ以来やってません
大学受験では
今度もう物理しかしませんでした
子どもの頃から パズルとか数学とか物理とか
好きだったんですが
どんな問題でもいいかっていうと
そうではなくて
例えば数学でも 計算とか
もう解けることが分かってる問題っていうのは
わざわざ答えを書くよりも
解答欄に「解けます」って書いて
終わりにしたいぐらい
一方で
解けるかどうか分からない問題
何時間とか
時には１日 ２日かけて解けた瞬間って
「よっしゃ！」って
自分自身に感動するんですよね
ここまでの人生
「７/７ワクワク」でした
だって好きなことしかしてないですもん
さて
この中で 週に１回以上
スポーツをする方って
どれぐらいいます？
ありがとう
じゃあ
スポーツをしてて ワクワクする時って
どんな時やと思います？
試合に勝った時とか
スコアが伸びた時とか
新しい道具買った時とか
いつもと違う場所でやった時とか
色々ありますよね
僕が思う
スポーツをしてて 一番ワクワクする時って
断然 上手くなる時
できないことができるようになった時
だと思います
先ほど手を挙げてもらった方は
ほとんどの方がアマチュアスポーツマン
だと思うんですが
それはアマチュアだけじゃなくて
プロでも
何歳になっても
上手くなるって 楽しいですよね
実は僕はアマチュアの
ウインドサーファーです
ウインドサーフィンには社会人になった時に
浜松に来て 初めて出会ったんですが
めちゃくちゃハマりました
僕はこのウインドサーフィンの中でも
フリースタイルっていう種目
やってるんですけど
海の上を滑走して ジャンプして
１〜２回転して技を決める
こんなスポーツです
残念ながらこれ僕じゃなくて
日本のフリースタイルチャンピオン
小林悠馬くんです
かっこいいでしょ
このウインドサーフィンのフリースタイル
めちゃくちゃ難しい
新しい技ができるようになるのに
半年とか１年とかかかるんですよ
何がそんなに難しいっていうと
僕が週末しかできないっていうのは
あるんですが
風を利用するめずらしいスポーツなんです
だから風と喧嘩してしまうと
道具が全く動かないどころか
もうめちゃくちゃ疲れる
一方で 風をうまく利用できれば少しの力で
１回転、２回転とか
波も使えば５メートル10メートルの高さに
ジャンプしたり
時速50キロ、60キロで走ったり
世界記録なんて時速100キロぐらい
出るんですよ
この半年とか
１年とかかかって
やっと新しい技ができた時
もう腹の底から突き上げるような感動ですよね
「よっしゃあーー！」って
「できたぁーー！」って
そう
ウインドサーフィンも
解けるかどうか分からない問題 だったんです
そして このとてつもない難しさと
それ以上の喜びを知ってしまったせいで
僕の頭の中は もう平日仕事中も全部
ウインドサーフィンになったんです
金曜日の夜なんて
土曜日ウインドサーフィンができる
って考えたら
もうワクワクしすぎて寝れないんですよ
毎週ですよ
毎週末 海外旅行に行ってるような
そんな気分
相対的に この平日の仕事の時間っていうのが
すごくつまらなく感じるようになったんです
人生が １週間の連続だとするなら
ウインドサーフィンができる 週末
２/７はワクワクするけど
残りの５/７は
ワクワクしない人生なのかって
そしてこれがずっと続くのかなって
思った時に
僕は人生の目標を
「７/７ワクワクすること」
に決めたんです
だけど このまま仕事を続けてたんでは
この２/７が ３/７に
なる気が全くしない
だから 会社を辞めて
１年間オーストラリアに行って
ウインドサーフィンだけをするって
決めたんです
最後になるかもしれないけど
もう一度この ７/７ワクワク
体験したいなって
オーストラリアに行って
ウインドサーフィン三昧の生活を
送ったんですが
意外とワクワクしなかった
日本にいたときは
アマチュアの大会に出場して優勝するって
目標があって
その同じ目標を持った仲間と
一緒に 練習してたんですが
この仲間がいないっていうのが
もう「しょうもな！」って
「俺ひとりだけ上手なって どないすんねん！」って
僕はウインドサーフィンが大好きだけど
それはただ ウインドサーフィンをする
ってことだけじゃなくて
同じ目標を持った仲間と ウインドをして
動画を撮り合って
一緒にごはん食べて
技術についてああだこうだ言い合うっていう
この全てのことが好きだったんだって
気づいたんです
想像してみてください
今 あなたに
すごい ワクワクすることがあったとして
でももしそれが 世界中で
あなたひとりしか やってないとしたら
ワクワクします？
７/７ワクワクするために
オーストラリアに行ったんですが
そこで気づいたのは
解けるかどうか分からない問題を
仲間と解くことの大切さでした
それでこのセンテンスの中に
ウインドサーフィンもスポーツも
入ってないやんって 気づいた時
ひょっとして
目標を決めて 仲間を集めて 起業すれば
ウインドでなくても
ワクワクできるかもしれない
しかも 食べていけるかもしれないって
思ったんです
なにしろ僕その時 結婚してたんで
だけど
日本に帰ってきてすぐに起業
とはいきませんでした
だって 日本にいると
ウインドサーフィン仲間がいて
やっぱり楽しい
平日仕事をして週末ウインドサーフィンをする
っていう生活に戻ってしまったんです
だけどそれから帰国して
半年ぐらい経った時
当時乗ってた車と
車に積んでた
ウインドサーフィンの道具ごと全部
盗まれたんです
もう嘘やろ・・・って
俺の人生の全てが・・・って
ウインドサーフィンの道具だけでも
100万円ぐらいするんですよ
コツコツ買ってきて
せめてウインドの道具は置いて
車だけ盗んでくれよ って
いや ほんまに
だけどこの時期
起業の準備をするために
お金を貯めるために
ウインドサーフィンを止めなきゃって
だけど楽しすぎて自分から止められない
そんなジレンマを抱えてたんです
で たまたま車を盗まれた
僕はこれを機に一気に思考を切り替えて
ウインドサーフィン中心の生活から
起業へと舵を切りました
すぐに元いたソフトウェア会社の仲間に
連絡して
「起業したい」
「一回集まろ」って
それから数ヶ月
アイデアを議論して
集まった仲間がたまたま
社会人とか 学生時代
スポーツに真剣に取り組んでたんで
スポーツに関すること
その中で最もワクワクすること
つまり うまくなることに役立つ
アプリケーション作ろって
決めたんです
じゃあどんなアプリ作るって
検討したときに
このスポーツのITって
プロとか オリンピックとか
トップアスリート向けのものばっかり
だったんです
でもこのトップアスリートって
世の中に１％もいないんですよ
だったら残りの99%
つまり アマチュアスポーツマンに
役立つことができるなって
しかも
まだこの誰も取り組んでない
アマチュアスポーツっていう分野の
ITの市場を作るっていうことは
まさに 解けるかどうか分からない問題
だったんです
僕らはこのアマチュア向けに
安価で 簡単に使える
アプリを作っています
例えば 撮影するだけで
走ったり 跳んだりのフォームが
チェックできるアプリとか
ゴルフとか野球のスイングが
可視化できるアプリ
それからチームスポーツの分析が
簡単にできるアプリとか
起業して
解けるかどうか分からない問題を
仲間と解くことで
ワクワクできるなって考えてたんですが
お客さんがワクワクしないで
自分たちだけがワクワクするなんてありえへん
誰かをワクワクさせることで
自分たちがワクワクする
そんなワクワクのスパイラルが
生み出せたら最高だなって
僕らの会社のスローガンは
『アマチュアスポーツマンの
「もっと上手くなりたい」を叶える』です
誰かが 僕らのアプリを触って
「ワクワクするなぁ！」って
言ってくれたら 最高に嬉しい
この解けるかどうか分からない問題を
仲間と 誰かのために解く
これが 今僕らのワクワクの源になっています
ここで僕が起業する時に 創業メンバーを
誘った時のエピソードをご紹介します
僕が「起業したい」って言うと
ひとりを除いてみんな「いいよ」って
ふたつ返事で快諾してくれたんです
ただそのひとりが
「実は 今の会社で成功が見えてるんです
昇進もしたし そろそろ家も買おうかなって
思ってるんです」って言うんですよ
いや マジで？
って 焦りました
だって彼も 僕らが起業するのに
欠かせないメンバーだったんで
僕は なんとか説得しなきゃって
もう頭フル回転させて考えたんです
確か彼は 学生時代
数学者目指してたよなって
だから僕と同じか僕以上に
数学が好きなはずだって
思ってこう聞いたんです
「もし 成功が見えてるんやったら
今 頭の中で それ想像して
その人生それで終わりでええやん」って
「もう解けてるやん」って
「解けることが分かってる問題と
俺たちと起業するっていう
解けるかどうかわからない問題
どっち選ぶ？」って聞いたんですよ
彼は
「後者ですね」って 言ってくれたんです
「やったー！」ですよ
起業して６年経つんですが
今 会社の中は 多国籍なメンバーに囲まれて
実は毎日 英語を使ってるんです
学生時代あんだけ苦手やったのに
嘘みたいでしょ？
でもなんでできるようになったかっていうと
勉強のための 英語 じゃなくて
ワクワクすることを成し遂げるための
手段になったからです
僕の人生の目標は
「７/７ワクワクすること」
冒頭にお話ししました
でもまだこの７/７に向かってる途中で
ウインドサーフィンは再開したんですけど
起業ってやっぱり大変で
もちろん
希望に満ちあふれた時もあるけど
不安で押しつぶされそうな時もある
だけど
解けることが分かる 楽な人生より
遥かに生きてるって 実感できる
そう
もう万年２/７じゃないです
そしていつかこの「？」が「５」になった時
つまり ７/７になった時
どんな会社になってると思います？
日曜日の夜に
月曜日の仕事のこと考えると
ワクワクしすぎて眠れない
そんな会社にしたいなって
僕のワクワクには３つの段階がありました
ひとつ目は
パズルとか数学とか物理とか
ハマってた学生時代
解けるかどうか分からない問題を
解くってことに夢中になってた
ふたつ目
ウインドサーフィンに熱中してた頃
ウインドの上達っていう難しい問題を
仲間と解く喜びに 気づきました
そして３つ目
起業したこと
起業するってことは仲間と
まだ解決できていない
誰かの問題を 解決することです
そしてその誰かから
ありがとうをもらった分だけ
僕たちのワクワクの源になります
ここにいる誰もが 子どもの頃
７/７ワクワクしてた頃が
きっと あると思います
今 あなたは
７分のいくつ ワクワクしてます？
そして もう一度
７/７ワクワクする人生にするために
さあ
何をしましょ？
（拍手）